what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu and we are now in
the multiverse saga which is really
exciting but at the same time we don't
exactly know what to expect from future
projects now we do know that our two
biggest and main projects of the
multiverse saga are going to be both
avengers films the kang dynasty and of
course avengers secret wars these two
films are truly going to dive into the
multiverse and show us a lot of
different variants about characters that
we know and love and of course new
characters as well but these projects
are really going to dive into the
multiverse not kind of like doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
where we thought it was going to be
completely insane a bunch of different
multiverses a bunch of different
variants and cameos when that ended up
not being the case however with avengers
secret wars and leading up to that the
kang dynasty that's what these two films
are going to be all about a bunch of
different variants which is super
exciting because i think this is what we
were all looking forward to in
multiverse of madness but didn't really
get it was a slight teaser for what was
to come right now the mcu with loki with
multiverse of madness with loki 2 they
are simply preparing us and teaching us
the rules of what is to come in further
projects with the actual multiverse so
knowing that and knowing that we are
finally going to be getting some other
variants let's talk about what variants
we could possibly see in the kang
dynasty and avengers secret wars now one
thing to keep in mind with seeing new
variants and new versions of characters
is that we could actually see some new
ones as early on as ant-man and the wasp
quantomania and there's actually
evidence to back this up because in the
trailer that has not been released
publicly yet but will be soon we hear
king actually say to ant-man you're an
avenger have i killed you before this
implies that kang has run into other
avengers before probably a lot of them
and has actually killed them so ant-man
and the wasp could bring us other
variants especially if we are going to
do flashbacks to who king is and what
he's done in the past present and future
but of course the big ones are going to
come in avengers secret wars where
incursions occur and multiverses collide
into each other eventually only having
one universe consisting of a lot of
different variants of the same
characters and there are many different
groups of characters that could be
appearing but i think the most exciting
groups of all the most exciting
characters that we could possibly see
show up in avengers secret wars and
other projects are dead characters and
not only dead characters but their
variants as well i'm talking about iron
man robert downing jr returning to play
a variant of tony stark and seeing
multiple variants of tony stark all
played by robert downing jr but at the
same time seen other variants of tony
stark as well and iron man played by
different actors like tom cruise we
didn't see this in multiverse of madness
but there is still a possibility that we
could see this happen in avengers secret
wars in fact this is actually the
perfect opportunity to see this happen
because this is the big one this is the
avengers end game and while it didn't
happen in doctor strange like i
mentioned that one was kind of teaching
us the rules of the multiverse and kind
of teasing us of what's to come well
avengers secret wars is when it comes
hopefully fingers crossed and although
captain america technically isn't dead
at least to our knowledge we could see
chris evans return and play steve rogers
and here's a really cool thought we
could also see john krasinski as captain
america because we know he auditioned to
play captain america but didn't get the
role but we do know that he played mr
fantastic in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and we will
probably see him even if he's not the
main read richers in the mcu return as a
variant of mr fantastic not the same one
that we saw in multiverse of madness of
course because that one is dead but
think about how cool it would be to see
john krasinski on screen as captain
america and john krasinski on screen as
mr fantastic as well standing right next
to each other that would be extremely
cool and is actually a possibility is
not a bad idea is actually a great idea
and is well within the realm of reality
that could happen for secret wars now of
course another dead character that we
could see is black widow we could see
the return of scarlett johansson playing
natasha romanov again this would not be
the same character because of course she
is dead but scarlett johansson could
return to play a variant of black widow
and out of all the cameos we could see
these are probably the most exciting
chris evans robert downey jr and
scarlett johansson returning to play
variants of themselves but there might
be one group of people that could be
even more exciting to see show up in
avengers secret wars and that is
characters from other franchises and i'm
talking about the fox x-men the fox
fantastic four and anyone else you could
think of but specifically i think
everybody knows who i'm talking about
and that is hugh jackman hugh jackman
returning to play a variant of wolverine
fans specifically want this and i really
want this because we want to see
deadpool ryan reynolds deadpool which we
know is about to enter the mcu right
next to hugh jackman's wolverine and of
course we don't count x-men origins
wolverine that doesn't count we want a
true deadpool and a true wolverine
played by hugh jackman and ryan reynolds
right next to each other in avengers
secret wars hopefully wolverine gets
introduced to the mcu relatively soon so
in avengers secret wars we get a bunch
of different wolverine variants and hugh
jackman is one of those variants i even
think it would be hilarious if we had a
variant of deadpool that is played by
hugh jackman and a variant of wolverine
that is actually played by ryan reynolds
this would be hilarious because deadpool
can break the fourth wall and can
actually comment on the fact that they
could have done an actor switch again
it's entirely possible in avengers
secret wars and of course the fantastic
four are coming to the mcu in 2024 we
don't know the official cast yet
hopefully that will be revealed at d23
but the possibility of seeing the
original fantastic four alongside of the
new fantastic four is very possible in
avengers secret wars they could even
bring the cast of the rebooted fantastic
four into the equation as well yes the
newest fantastic four movie wasn't that
well received however perhaps they could
have some type of multiversal redemption
arc kind of like andrew garfield got in
spider-man no way home now of course if
we're going to see variants of the old
x-men hopefully we could get a lot of
new x-men as well because remember all
of the different teams that there are
are going to come together even if we
don't have that team in our specific
universe that most likely exist in
another universe like how we don't
really have the illuminati in our
universe right now that didn't stop it
from existing in another universe so
even if a wolverine isn't introduced in
our universe before secret wars there is
still a possibility he could be in
another universe in fact we know for a
fact he exists in another universe the
fox universe now from here on out things
are just going to get crazy cool because
we're going to take the teams that we
already have and see different variants
of them and also not to mention villains
as well it's not just heroes but
villains like doom and of course we all
know that the kang dynasty is going to
be all about the king variants so expect
to see a lot of kang variants as well
but of course we could see the return of
thanos we could also see ultron really
anyone is on the table and then we're
going to take our teams like the
avengers and see a bunch of different
variants of them like falcon aka the new
captain america bucky wanda doctor
strange wong the hulk and of course like
i mentioned other characters that aren't
in our universe right now like captain
carter iron man and of course let's not
forget all of the different variants of
spider-man we've already gotten two and
the actual mcu and there are more out
there then of course you have the
guardians of the galaxy star-lord rocket
groot drax mantis gamora nebula then we
have nova who is coming to the mcu adam
warlock craglin yondu could return and
we could even get thanos as a good guy
kind of like we saw in what if all
different variants of all of these
people and one team that i'm actually
really excited to see some variants on
and actually just see them show up in
the mcu is the supernatural team moon
knight blade werewolf by night ghost
writer imagine nicholas cage returning
as ghost writer fighting alongside of
patrick stewart's professor x and hugh
jackman's wolverine this is what i hope
they deliver with in avengers secret
wars because the potential is there and
it is the big event i don't think we
ever really thought we were going to see
all the teams we saw together in
avengers in-game actually together but
we did and now this is going to be even
bigger than avengers in game secret wars
is going to take all of these groups and
bring them together in groups from other
universes and that includes everyone i
mentioned and of course other groups
like the eternals we could see star fox
pip thena cersei they might not actually
have variants because they were kind of
created but so is ultron and we know
that there are ultron variants but
seeing them and daredevil and she-hulk
and ekko alongside of the avengers and
the fantastic four and the x-men that's
what secret wars should be and that's
what it is in the comics so hopefully
marvel studios is going that way and i
believe they are but let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and let me know who you would
like to see together in avengers secret
wars don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof